[Music]
it's not something many of us like
talking about but what you're flushing
down your toilet
is helping researchers in the valley
track covered 19.
the i-team's david charns got an inside
look at how scientists are using
what's in the sewer to get a better idea
of what's happening
above ground
everybody does it i don't think it's
something that somebody thinks about
when they flush the toilet but
there's definitely value to what's going
down the toilet
from toilet to treatment what we're
putting in the sewer
is helping scientists track spikes in
coronavirus
before they're identified principal
research scientist daniel garrity is the
one
with the dirty job every monday every
week
it's him and two gallon jugs at the
flamingo resource center
a sprawling facility handling 100
million gallons of our sewage a day
but the sample garrity takes to his lab
is just a snapshot
a moment in time a pinch
from the plumbing so as cases go up our
wastewater concentrations go up
and then as cases go down our wastewater
concentrations go down here's why
while we think of coronavirus as
primarily affecting our lungs
parts of the virus cause secondary
infections
and that's what shows up in what we
flush it basically gives us an
opportunity to swallow the
entire community all at one time take a
look at those swabs on this chart
from the start of the pandemic to now
the blue bars represent new cases
the green dots how much covid is in
garrity samples
he and his team predicted a spike in
cases in june
before testing then validated those
cases
the same thing happened after
thanksgiving and christmas
let's say over the past month it's
increased at least 10-fold across the
board
that's a pretty big jump from what we've
seen since we started
researchers are also finding fewer cases
of
other contagious diseases suggesting
what we're doing to prevent covid
is pulling double duty and so the normal
illnesses diseases that people get
we don't see that as much because people
are being more cautious to try to
prevent themselves from getting coveted
19.
for now garrity will keep his monday
routine
as mother nature calls this scientist
will continue to study
what we're leaving behind wastewater is
often viewed as something disgusting
that people just want to go away
but actually from a scientific
perspective it gives us a window into
the community
part of that window is tracking other
viruses even opioid misuse or how much
caffeine we're drinking researchers over
at unlv are also studying these samples
focusing on the makeup of the virus
and tracking any mutations now all of
this research will become
even more important as more of us get
vaccinated
to determine just how effective the
vaccine is and is going to be
i'm david charns 8 news now